[Musique]
obama au ghana et au pistolet tu tiens
beaucoup plus vite que toi moi je suis
le plus fort en un mot c'est gérard hier
ça vous tient de situations les plus
périlleuses pour sûr dorothée tué la
fille du soliste je vais t'emmener dans
ma vie j'en 5
nous allons nous enfuir loin des indiens
way le bétail a passé la frontière voilà
sa tâche ne pas tomber en arrière et
bien écoute match à dorothée moi aussi
je suis très content d'être à récré a2
et je ne suis pas venu comme ça j'ai
apporté des petites chansons pour toi le
rhdp oui les petites chansons seulement
comme je ne savais pas faire ce genre de
chanson tu aimais alors j'en ai composé
trois petits trois petites différentes
une ballade rock and roll 1 une petite
berceuse
gprenc écoute attention
[Musique]
dans les faits
c'est un livre d'histoire un jour s'est
envolé comme
ap
elle connaît des secrets letter santé
elle descendit les oreilles
[Musique]
je veux être ton ami
tu me racontes
les histoires de souris
et plus
peux tu être mon ami
pour m'apprendre à chanter comme un
grand k now
alors ma vie aussi dorothée que tu es
aimé danser que tu dansais très bien et
que tu dansais aussi je crois que moi
alors je lui de chanter le taux voté
blanc qui arrange
dorothée avec toi tu peux danser
dorothée avec toi je chantais tout l'été
on va bien rigoler pour ma mère
mais plus
donner
le bagad an
m
le
la bouche de beaucoup plus calme
maintenant monsieur bien une petite
berceuse
on va je dois faire tu veux la panthère
c'est la première rose mais elle est
tombée dans un encrier alors la petite
berceuse s'affaisser
des leurs sur son oreiller je viendrai
s'éveiller
dom d'or alors
dans la nuit de l'été les oiseaux ont
chanté
rêve rêve de voter
au dessin animé
et une histoire
et rêve
dans
les moines parmi nous
dans tes yeux on rit
là
une
vu dans des oeufs
m
pour mm
devant les tranquilles quand on est bien
là on peut discuter
qu'est ce que tu t'es là mais non c'est
parce que je suis gay chanson toi paris
to crack mais lyon j'ai pas fait de
bruit je venais juste pour parler de
l'émission de demain si mais si j'ai des
choses très importantes à dire très très
très très compliqué il faut expliquer
tout ça tout le monde tout de suite oui
mais non là et tout de suite tu veux
s'il vous plaît d'accord d'accord tu as
choisi l'émission va être présenté et
cévennes par gérard les semaines passées
de gira ça n'empêche pas de toute façon
je pouvais tu parleras d'une ve est pas
mais ça ne veut pas ça ne veut pas j'ai
toujours c'est à toi de jouer très bien
ah bah vous partez bon et fabrice je te
rappelle que demain il faut que tu sois
là pour la foire apprivoiser un aléa
demain bon eh bien écoutez nous vous
savez ce qu'on va faire on va prendre un
nouveau cahier oui on va prendre le
cahier de récréation que récréation il y
avait le cahier d'arithmétique le cahier
de lecture le cahier de dessin et bien
nous avons inventé le cahier de
récréation et nous allons voir ensemble
le programme de tout l'été suivez-moi
alors voilà mon cas hier regarder il est
beau il est tout neuf et j'ai à côté de
moi un tableau mais c'est un tableau un
petit peu magique car il suffit que je
fasse ça et hop il apparaît aussitôt le
programme inscrit dessus à la craie
blanche c'est formidable voilà alors
tout d'abord nous avons une rubrique de
jeu de jeu alors les jeux tactiles sont
là voilà vous avez entendu la forêt
apprivoiser avec pouces moussu avec bell
bell avec tout quand nous les retrouvons
dès demain avec fabrice dans une petite
cabane qui l'ont construit et nous les
retrouverons demain
ensuite nous avons un autre jeu qui
s'appelle papy vol qui était un jeu avec
des dessins et des découpages qui fera
un peu appel à votre sens de
l'observation
il faudra bien garder ça s'appelle papy
vol et puis bien sûr nous aurons un tas
d'autres jeux des devinettes des
charades des histoires que dorothée et
moi nous vous raconterons ensuite nous
avons une deuxième rubrique qui
s'appelle reportages et information est
tout d'abord une série qui s'intitule je
veux être toi je veux être toi qu'est ce
que c'est et bien voilà
nous allons avoir des invités qui vont
nous parler de leur métier ils vont nous
expliquer comment on devient moins deux
motards comment on devient cuisinier
comment on devient aviateurs je ne sais
pas et chaque jour nous les retrouverons
dans une nouvelle émission ils vous
parleront un petit peu de leur métier et
comme ça si vous voulez devenir un jour
pilote et bien vous en serez déjà pas
mal ensuite nous avons une émission qui
s'intitule entre les lignes
et bien c'est une émission qui nous
permettra de rentrer dans la
bibliothèque des enfants et nous verrons
avec eux des vivres et ils nous
raconteront un petit peu comment
commence on s'est livré est si ça leur a
plu si ça les intéresse je crois que
cette émission très très très très
intéressante dès la semaine prochaine je
crois oui dès la semaine prochaine nous
allons faire connaissance avec un petit
bébé phoque qui s'appelle grave graf qui
est arrivé un jour sur le sur la plage
en suède je crois et qui était
recueillie par une famille c'est une
très très belle histoire que nous
verrons ensemble à partir de la semaine
prochaine
et enfin pour terminer cette rubrique
est bien la clé des sons la clé des
sceaux qu'est ce que c'est et bien les y
avoir des enfants qui vont mettre des
images et des dessins sur un morceau de
musique que je crois que c'est très très
intéressant voilà pour les reportages
des informations maintenant les dessins
animés alors là nous en avons une foule
je voulais sites comme ça dans le
désordre il y aura la panthère rose il y
aura à casper et ses amis il y aura
lippi le lion et puis encore beaucoup
d'autres choses
après les dessins animés nous passons
maintenant au feuilleton les feuilletons
bien il y en a beaucoup
y'en a beaucoup également il y en a un
qui s'intitule tout d'abord je crois que
c'est un feuilleton vous allez voir très
prochainement qui s'intitule les
aventures de gulliver vous connaissez
l'univers c'est un monsieur qui était
parti avec un bateau son bateau a coulé
il s'est retrouvé sur une île et sur
cette île il y avait de tout petits
petits bonshommes qui s'appelait les
lilliputiens
voilà nous les retrouverons très
prochainement ensuite la grotte aux fées
ça se passe je crois dans une grotte
mystérieuse et des enfants qui ont fait
des découvertes pas je veux pas vous en
dire plus les aventures du professeur
pas peur le professeur popper est un
personnage assez sympathique qui est un
chimiste un scientifique qui découvre un
tas de formule ensuite nous avons
monsieur rosé personnage aussi très très
bizarre puisqu'ils se déplacent en
ballon je crois qu'il a un chapeau melon
et
il ya quelqu'un qui lui ressemble
énormément alors ça fait ça fait toute
une histoire ensuite robinson crusoé à
la robinson crusoé bon vous connaissez
sûrement l'histoire de robinson crusoé
qui lui aussi a fait naufrage qui s'est
retrouvé tout seul perdu dans une île
déserte mais à nous avons un robinson
crusoé un petit peu particulier puisque
nous allons voir robinson crusoé au
théâtre au petit théâtre des
marionnettes
voilà et pour terminer alors nous avons
un nouveau feuilleton qui ce sera la
premier le premier épisode aujourd'hui
qui s'intitule goldorak
qu'est-ce que goldorak et bien goldorak
c'est un feuilleton japonais qui se
passe en l'an 2000 884 sur une petite
planète très loin entre mars et vénus je
crois qu'ils s'appellent petite planète
bleue et qui a un tas un tas d'histoires
vous allez voir il ya des soucoupes
volantes il ya des fusées il ya un tas
de choses
enfin nous allons voir dans quelques
instants le premier épisode voilà je
vous ai donné
en gros le programme pour tout l'été
bien sûr il va y avoir des choses qui
vont s'ajouter il va y avoir les
histoires il va y avoir un tas de choses
nouvelles et je vous demande je vous
demande de nous envoyer une petite carte
à dorothée est à moi pour nous tenir au
courant pour nous dire si vous aimez le
feuilleton pour savoir si vous voulez
d'autres jeux nous allons tout
simplement je vous explique clairement
tout simplement nous allons faire le
programme ensemble alors nous envoyer
des petites cartes postales à récré a2
et on fera le programme tous ensemble
voilà là tu seras très bien ici voilà je
vous présente alphonse c'est un tigre
qui vient du bengale il ne mord pas ils
ne crient pas il ne bouge pas pour tout
vous dire car je crois qu'il dort toute
la journée il a été piqué au bengale par
une mouche qui est la mouche tsé-tsé qui
donne la maladie du sommeil
il est très gentil regarder on peut même
monter dessus voilà là à
bon ben on est bien ici c'est notre
grenier en fait c'est le grenier de la
grand-mère à dorothée à nous le prête
alors on y vient et puis on apporte des
objets tout ce qu'on veut on aime bien
dorothée mois trouver des objets un peu
extraordinaire envoyé à plein de choses
il ya une girafe
il ya deux sculptures en bois ils ont
été sculptées il s'appelle jules et
celui là il s'appelle bill
ils ont été sculptées dans un dans une
forêt américaine par une tribu d'indiens
qui s'appelle la tribu des nez rouges
voyez c'est pour ça que
lula nez rouge lui aussi à nez rouge
mais lui en plus je crois qu'il a pris
un petit coup de soleil c'est pour ça
qu'il est très rouge ça va ça va ah ça
ça alors là ça mes enfants il ne faut
surtout pas y toucher car ça c'est le
coin réservé à dorothée dorothée et
figurez-vous se livre à des expériences
de chimie
et oui elle a décidé elle s'est mis dans
la tête de trouver une formule magique
qui lui permettrait de tout transformer
en bombe on savait que dorothée juillet
entre nous mais elle est un petit peu
gourmande
alors ça je n'y touche pas il ya encore
plein d'autres objets il ya un
scaphandrier il ya un bateau il ya à ja
l'appareil photo alors là je vais vous
demander de je vais vous demander de
vous mettre devant votre poste de
télévision car figurez vous que cet
appareil photo est magique
il permet de prendre les photos à
travers la télévision alors rassemblé
vous tous mettez-vous en groupe
voilà voilà vous souriez au moment où je
dis 3 vous seriez d'accord et je prends
la photo attention un deux trois clics
voilà j'espère que ça a marché je
voudrais voir la photo un jour ça c'est
ça c'est ma poussette quand j'étais
petit j'allais j'allais faire le marché
j'allais aux courses avec avec ma
poussette et puis ça ça c'est ma guitare
alors je vous ai bien sûr avoue aussi
préparé une petite chanson qui comme
c'est la première émission bien sûr
parle de la récréation ça s'appelle vive
la récré
filles et les garçons jouer pour eux
dans tous les coins comme des oiseaux
dans le jardin ou qui se poursuivent et
se tiennent par la main
aux gendarmes et aux voleurs on y met
tout son coeur attrape moi si tu le peux
tu as triché c'est pas du jeu
du lundi au samedi le ciel est bleu
et
l'arrivée du pivot des vacances la
récréation
c'est comme un bonbon
ils veulent aller
les vacances
avec création c'est ce que nous vous
on joue à la marelle à la marie gros l
achat perché à chapeauter à cash campo
dans la céder à la récré c'est tout le
temps les bus
riga
les gars aux cheveux là
gentiment on suffoque les fils et filles
aussi taquine les gars finalement on se
prend par le bras
ivre l'avait créée et vive les vacances
avec les assurances c'est comme un
bonbon
arrêtés s'ils veulent et vacances
avec création
c'est ce que nous longue à la récréation
c'est la même chanson en criant
elle y vient on joue si aux quatre coins
on pourrait s'envoler dès le matin
faire des bêtises et chanter à tue tête
manger des bonbons aux cerises par tous
grillés fn a fait chanter les chansons
qu'on a dans la tête
avec une vive les vacances la récréation
c'est comme un bonbon
vive la récré vive les vacances
avec des nations c'est ce que nous
voulons rejoindre soit vous